let's bring you more on our top story
and
matt hancock there downing street says
the prime minister
has accepted health secretary matt
hancock's apology for breaching social
distancing guidelines
and considers the matter closed
asked whether boris johnson had full
confidence in mr hancock the spokesman
has replied yes so downing street
accepts matt hancock's apology
for breaching social distancing
guidelines and considers
the matter closed mr hancock spoke to
skies k
burley back in september you'll remember
urging
couples from separate households to
abide by the letter
and the spirit of the guidelines
it just means that people need to be
careful right people need to be sensible
and if you're in a relationship that is
uh
that is well established you know that's
that's what like six months
what it means is not people be
realizing that by
by coming into close contact with people
in
other households then that is
how the virus spreads i wouldn't suggest
bending the rules i would suggest
sticking to them
letter and spin okay